merci monsieur le Président d'abord vous
dire quand même parce que je vois que ça
en fait rire certains parlent de cinéma
moi je trouve quand même que le moment
il est grave il est grave il est lourd
et franchement l'image et je vais le
dire quand même l'image que vous donnez
on a débattu on a débattu on a des battu
longuement pendant trois jours on est
arrivé à cet article en cet article 7 il
n'y avait aucune raison d'interrompre ce
débat et de vouloir passer en force
comme le vous le faites et puis ensuite
on entrave ce soir notre droit
d'amendement parce que franchement on
dépose des choses amendements c'est
impossible matériellement de pouvoir
faire ce que vous avez fait donc c'est
une entrave au droit d'amendement c'est
une entrave au droit parlementaire à
notre travail de parlementaire moi je
suis peiné effectivement que ça se passe
ici et que ça se passe ici au Sénat je
pense qu'on avait donné une bonne image
et que là on donne une image vous donner
une image désastreuse donc avec
l'ensemble des trois groupes
effectivement nous allons quitter
l'assemblée mais je peux vous dire que
les sénatrices et les sénateurs de nos
trois groupes ne le font pas de gaieté
de coeur franchement on avait mieux à
faire ce soir on a bien mieux à faire
toute cette semaine pour contexte
effectivement d'importance un texte qui
est attendu avec des gens qui ont défilé
aujourd'hui en nombre que ça vous plaise
ou pas et que cette place au débat elle
était importante donc on va partir et on
le regrette ou ferez ce que vous voulez
cette nuit nous on reviendra demain et
j'espère qu'on pourra revenir dans des
conditions un peu plus sereine pour
pouvoir débattre et travailler
sereinement merci à toi de la Présidente
je voudrais